je souhaiterais vous informer ainsi que
les collègues que j'ai été victime de
violences policières de la part de la
police belge
je considère cela comme un acte
dissemination discriminatoire à tendance
raciste
hier en sortant de la gare du nord j'ai
vu neuf policiers harceler de zones
noires
j'avais mon téléphone en main j'ai fait
une photo de la scène avec mon téléphone
ce qui est légal les policiers se sont
dirigés vers moi ils m'ont arraché mon
téléphone des mains
quatre des neuf policiers armés m'ont
brutalement poussé contre le mur
ils ont violemment pris mon sac à main
ils m'ont plaqué au mur jambes écartées
et là un policier voulais me tester me
fouiller
ils m'ont traitée de façon humiliante
quand j'ai dit aux policiers que j'étais
député au parlement aux ports européens
il ne m'a pas cru alors qu'il avait en
main mon de mes deux passeports
c'est le laissez-passer du parlement
européen
le passeport allemand là dessus il m'a
demandé la carte de résidence de la
belgique
je lui ai donné la carte de la résidence
j'ai pris dans mon sac mon match et
j'avais le badge autour de moi j'ai
porté plainte aujourd'hui car on ne peut
pas laisser passer ces violences
policières
cette expérience à l'heure où le monde
entier a vu les conséquences fâcheuses
de la brutalité policière
et pour moi traumatisant mais je suis là
bien que j'ai passé toute la nuit ici au
parlement pour écrire je n'ai pas eu le
courage de sortir jusqu'à 6 heures du
matin j'étais ici hier on peut le
vérifier avec nos badges
nous devons donc prendre des mesures
concrètes pour bon nombre de personnes
qui ne sont pas ici et qui n'ont pas pu
échapper à la violence policière
je vous remercie
sur le volet si grave si on aurait vu le
père la shoah signal actionnaires et
naturel même si les siens movie chiny
been christine chiomento l'invitant à
venir un ennemi aux fiches opérait la
compagnie née détaillé colloque est de
notre côté qui aiderait à thierry mento
à les autorit à bergues credo qu'elle
devra nom de l'inspiration et la
libération prague au président
[Musique]